is drug maker pfizer requesting  emergency youth authorization from the  fda today  for its covid19 vaccine which may be 95  percent effective  pending approval the company expecting  to begin delivering its first shots  as soon as next month within weeks we  could have a decision from fda  and within 24 hours of that we will have  started distributing millions of doses  of safe and effective vaccine to begin  protecting our most  vulnerable across america here at home  health officials have been preparing our  state's vaccine plan for when one  becomes available  today we got a look at one of the  storage areas at unlv  they tell us this freezer will be able  to keep the vaccine  at negative 80 degrees celsius coming up  at six we're going to hear from the  doctor in charge